bonsoir et bienvenue dans kiosque votre
émission culturelle au menu ce soir de
belles rencontres Bernard Delattre
journalistes Vinois vient de publier
chaîne given entre le Tao et Mao un
récit autour d'une famille pour mieux
comprendre un peu l'histoire de la Chine
Barbara Hendrick c'est venu au prismaël
on court Nicolas Gervais a rencontré
cette grande dame du blues et du jazz
une interview à retrouver dans kiosque
en toute intimité et puis Gwenaëlle
Roussel auteur compositrice lance un
projet d'un album quatre titres autour
de la femme de Merlin via un financement
participatif
on peut retrouver ce soir dans kiosque
de la trop bonsoir vous êtes l'auteur
chez L'Harmattan de tiennent entre le
Tao et Mao la grande déchirure voilà
c'est un livre qui fait plus de 340
pages et qui disait donc à une femme un
peu extraordinaire nous allons nous
parler je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste de presse locale sur les
Yvelines tout le monde tout le monde
vous connaît là vous évoquez
effectivement le témoignage de given
d'abord comment vous l'avez rencontré
cette femme quand j'étais journaliste
donc sur Rambouillet j'étais journaliste
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et sur
Rambouillet et sur Rambouillet donc
Kenji van c'était présenté plusieurs
fois l'élection présidentielle en France
elle n'a pas recueilli un les 500
signatures nécessaires
on avait parlé tout et c'était elle se
présentait pour promouvoir les idées
qu'on fusionnistes et ça ça m'avait ça
m'avait plus que j'avais envie d'aller
voir puis donc j'avais fait une
entretien chez elle et j'avais découvert
que de toute sa famille était dans la
presse quoi donc comme je suis
impressionné de presse son père était un
peu le laser rêve chinois c'est-à-dire
son père de simples étudiant ils sont
arrivés à monter le plus grand quotidien
de Pékin ça c'était du temps où la Chine
n'était pas encore
donc vous avez
rencontré son témoignage c'était un
travail qui a demandé du temps c'est ça
oui un an quand j'allais la voir une
fois par semaine avec son mari je
faisais entretiens magnétophone je dois
avoir 25 cassettes d'une heure d'une
heure 30 et le donc le mercredi c'était
mon jour de repos à l'époque jéscrivais
tout ça puis je le représentais la
semaine d'après et puis on a avancé
toute l'histoire de cette femme mais
quand même pour raconter un peu le début
vous l'avez dit c'est ses parents
étaient des des des créateurs de
journaux des éditeurs de journaux à
Pékin avant que la Chine soit soit
communiste qu'est-ce qui lui est arrivé
au moment où les communistes se sont
arrivés en Chine ils ont été obligé de
fuir quoi ils sont réfugiés d'abord à
Shanghai après Hong Kong et ensuite à
Taiwan mais déjà il avait déjà été
obligé de se réfugier avant c'était
pendant le conflit sino sinon japonais
et là ça recommencé avec le conflit Mao
Shanka chic et d'autant plus que le père
de Sullivan monsieur Chen était
défendait de chancachek il a été député
de chiangle donc ils ont tout perdu ils
avaient un immeuble avec un journal ils
étaient assez aisés parce que leur
quotidien se vendait à plusieurs
millions d'exemplaires ils sont partis
avec rien quoi à la va vite et à Taïwan
ils avaient plus rien son père est
reparti à zéro et il a fondé une école
de journalisme à quel moment est arrivé
en France en 51 le 11 novembre 1951
alors il y a plein
partout
tout est fermé c'est ça je crois
tout est fermé elle est arrivée en
France elle s'est installée à
Rambouillet c'était dans les années 60
dans les années 50 et donc elle a épousé
Philippe Bertrand qui était un officier
de marine qui a été officiel de marine
au tokinois quoi pendant la guerre de et
donc ils ont acheté une maison à
Rambouillet ils ont construit une pagode
une grande pagode tout à fait dans le
dans le style chinois quoi dans l'esprit
chinois une pagode au togonale c'est un
vrai on peut la visiter
ouais il faut les appeler prendre
rendez-vous avec eux et quand on est au
pied de cette pagode on se croirait
vraiment en Asie quoi aller à octogonale
en bois il y a toutes les règles du Yin
Yang tout ça mais il faut les appeler
pour la visiter quoi alors
je comprends aussi qu'elle a elle porte
une philosophie
le Tao le Tao alors dans le livre elle
explique justement ce qu'est le
bouddhisme le confusionisme et le Tao
elle dit que le Tao c'est c'est pas une
religion c'est plus qu'une philosophie
et une science elle dit que c'est un
ordre de ivre la longévité elle dit que
le principal conflit a gagné c'est celui
de la longévité elle a elle arrive ainsi
à 90 ans tout un art de vivre une espèce
de sagesse millénaire façon de voir les
choses c'est très intéressant toute une
philosophie elle est elle critique un
peu Mao le régime de Pékin donc déjà les
garde-rouges c'est des millions de morts
ça fait des millions de morts ils
arrivaient dans les maisons ceux qui
avaient des lunettes c'était des
dangereuses intellectuels ont cassé les
lunettes au mieux on les envoyait on les
envoya à la campagne gratter la terre
mais des fois on les aiguille quoi elle
raconte tout ça voilà donc le Tao et
puis aussi c'est une concertiste assez
c'est une artiste avant tout disons
qu'elle est elle est pianiste de haut
niveau concertiste elle est aussi
compositrice elle va vous jouer du
Beethoven puis là elle va dire ah ben là
c'est un peu trop répétitif moi je
l'aurais fait différemment avec plus de
variants et c'est j'ai jamais vu ça quoi
c'est un personnage fantastique et en
plus elle est aussi poétesse elle fait
des poèmes elle a fait des symphonies
avec des poèmes des petites gens comme
des musicales et aussi pas elle a fait
des expositions de peinture elle a donné
des concerts à Hong Kong pk Shanghai
mais aussi à Paris Salle Gaveau tout ça
c'est vraiment elle joue toujours du
piano et qu'est-ce qui vous touche chez
ce personnage alors est-ce que c'est la
même typicité de la vie parce qu'on sent
qu'elle a eu une vie très très riche
très étonnante vas-y et moi c'est tout
de suite je lui ai dit quand elle m'a
raconté un peu sa vie je dis faut faire
un roman faut raconter tout ça quoi
c'est un témoignage historique c'est un
témoignage qui va rester dans l'histoire
mais elle me dit vous savez moi
l'écriture c'est pas mon truc je peux
vous aider tout ça et voilà c'est parti
comme ça parce que c'est plus une
musicienne voir poète et voilà je l'ai
un peu aidé j'ai eu un rôle plus de si
vous voulez de
c'est sur le livre c'est surtout elle a
tout le mérite du livre virer
si vous voulez de voilà
et demain
elle sera présente à Rambouillet et
certaines personnes pour le la
rencontrer d'ailleurs on essaie de faire
une conférence de presse pour faire
connaître le livre donc vous venez je
vous remercie il y aura des journalistes
Yvelines on espère de Paris mais c'est
pas facile pareil Rambouillet c'est une
expédition en tout cas si on a envie de
retrouver le livre et de vous rencontrer
aussi il y a deux dates de dédicaces
donc le 21 février c'est tout proche ce
sera à Rambouillet au centre Leclerc
Rambouillet et puis le 6 juin il y a du
temps mais au pavé du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux souviendrait
dédicacer cet ouvrage donc un récit de
l'histoire de la vie de given avec des
photos aussi il y a des photos qui
illustrent à la fin on retrouve un peu
toute sa famille donc c'est toute une
page de l'histoire chinoise qui
racontait dans ce dans ce livre édité
chez L'Harmattan merci beaucoup Bernard
d'être venu sur le sur le plateau de
kiosque et puis pour connaître un peu
plus ce personnage on pourra leur
retrouver dans le journal d'information
demain sur sur tvfilm puisqu'elle vient
effectivement à Rambouillet présenter
aussi ce livre merci on va poursuivre on
poursuit avec une page exposition
alors on va rester dans le milieu
asiatique l'artiste japonais ykouchi
iwanais présente plus d'une centaine de
ses visages sculptés dans la pierre à la
salle d'exposition de Guyancourt
découverte d'une œuvre qui se veut un
symbole de l'histoire passée et à venir
c'était découvrir jusqu'au 1er mars
regardez ce reportage très inspiré de
William elle
des dizaines de visages s'observent
silencieusement avec une émotion figée
dans la pierre une pierre du Japon chère
ayukishi Noé cette roche volcanique
blanche de l'île d'Okinawa témoin du
temps qui passe comme cette célèbre
bataille de 1945
pour cette bataille
mon père qui a été mon père a été
mobilisé et puis il a été tué en tant
que
deuxième classe actuellement je
connaissais pas mon père parce que
j'étais très jeune notre petit quoi donc
cette histoire
pour moi au quinoa toujours attaché à
cause de cette histoire
si vous voulez pour l'exposition mille
et une tête yukishi nous reste cultes
des centaines de visages dans son
matériau de prédilection comme des
instantanés pris sur le vif la tête
quand même c'est une c'est un symbole de
l'histoire de l'homme et puis l'homme a
utilisé à discuter depuis 1000 années et
pour faire des têtes soit sur le pied ou
soit avec le bois
donc la tête c'est un symbole de
l'histoire passée et puis l'histoire à
l'avenir aussi une histoire modelée par
le temps et les hommes à l'image du
travail de yukishinoé il taille directe
dans la pierre frappé dégrossies
réponses pour révéler une forme dans la
roche l'histoire inscrite dans la
matière
cet acte de de
blocs pour moi c'est une sorte de
comme histoire qu'on a on a répété
toujours
la paix et la guerre autrement dit des
solutions distribution et puis le
construction
ce paradoxe que je présente cette
manière de travail avec les pierres
après je travaille
j'ai recollé recomposer
je me sens vraiment
je n'ai pas quoi en fait
d'après la légende japonaise du temple
des mille et un bouddha on pouvait
retrouver dans le visage des statues les
traits des êtres chers éloignés ou
décédés
s'inspire de cette histoire pour ses
sculptures gardiennes de l'éternité de
l'homme et des empreintes successives du
temps qui passe
et puis à noter qu'une visite guidée est
programmée ce vendredi à 12h15 ainsi que
dans le cadre des ateliers du mercredi
le 18 février de 14h à 16h visite guidée
atelier et goûté pour les familles sont
proposées une autre exposition cette
fois pour comprendre les techniques de
la gravure et de la reliure c'est en ce
moment et jusqu'au 22 février à la ferme
du Mousseau d'Élancourt vous pourrez
découvrir les créations de deux ateliers
de la ville elle exposition est
accessible tout le week-end et l'entrée
et libre
comme tous les mercredis la chronique de
Nicolas Gervais ce soir elle nous
propose une rencontre avec Barbara
Hendrick à l'occasion de sa venue au
prisme à Élancourt
c'est une voix exceptionnelle que nous
recevons aujourd'hui après avoir chanté
de la musique classique et du jazz elle
s'intéresse désormais au blues elle
était le 4 février au prisme à Élancourt
et c'est là que nous l'avons rencontré
pour son dernier spectacle voici madame
Barbara Hendrix dans le kiosque toi tu
dors mais tu dors Patrick je t'ai vu tu
dors si tu es pas dans les coups tu
ah oui c'est un grand plaisir de d'être
ici je suis diplomique
nous sommes tout près de Paris et
c'était pas du tout un public parisien
dans un sens très très positif
j'ai commencé de chanter jazz il a
presque 20 ans maintenant c'était Nazar
que j'étais invité chanter un hommage à
ducal international jazz de Montreux
comme mon voisin Claude noble qui était
le directeur et fondateur de festival ça
m'a pris deux ans de préparer le
programme en écoutant que la musique de
kellington pas de chanteurs
il avait 10 ans que j'avais décidé qu'il
avait une partie de des racines de jazz
que je connaissais pas très bien
parce que enfant j'ai chanté à l'église
mon père était pasteur et qui trouvait
qu'il blouse n'était pas très convenable
quand j'ai commencé de regarder bon j'ai
trouvé une musique qui m'a beaucoup
touché et aussi j'ai appris que cette
musique joue un rôle aussi dans la lutte
pour les droits civiques aux États-Unis
le blues avait commencé dans les années
20 sur les plantes à plantations de
coton
dont vraiment dans la partie
des États-Unis ou les reins c'était
totalement séparées il commençait à
chanter jouer la musique pour s'exprimer
pas seulement la souffrance mais aussi
l'espoir pour enlever une vie meilleure
les racines les vrais racines de blues
c'est vraiment dans
l'Afrique parce que cette musique c'est
rythme ça vient de l'Afrique avec les
esclaves
Mongolie
and blood
apparition
moi j'aime comme je l'ai dit j'aime
beaucoup le la musique chambre et
j'ai toujours aimé
la guitare et quand j'avais décidé de
faire blues j'avais décidé de faire ça
avec
guitare et puis alors d'abord sur les
scènes plus grands dehors en plein air
nous sommes obligés de
ajouter batterie et basse pour pour
remplir un peu l'espace mais moi je
préfère en trio parce que c'est très
intime et dans une salle comme ce soir
pour moi c'était idéal pour faire ce
concert
quand je chante le blues ou un air de
Mozart c'est la même voix mais c'est la
différence c'était notre langue c'est
comme quand je parle quand je parle en
anglais on suédois ma voix est
différente et ce n'est pas quelque chose
que je fais exprès que moi chaque
compositeur à sa langue et c'est ça que
j'essaie de parler la langue de la
musique que je chante
on a un petit tour même maintenant ici
on février
et après au mois de à la fin du mois je
serai à la Côte d'Ivoire pour une
conférence là la patrie pour le HCR pour
le commissariat des réfugiés parce qu'il
a 10 millions de personnes qui ne sont
qui sont citoyens nulle part et ça c'est
inacceptable début mars je suis marraine
de festival de films des doigts des
droits humains à Genève et je serai là
et voilà c'était donc Barbara Hendricks
et maintenant on retrouve celle qui elle
aussi a trouvé sa voix Catherine sur le
plateau du kiosque
allez pour continuer dans le domaine de
la musique mais de la musique sacrée
cette fois-ci concert autour du quatuor
pour la fin du temps d'Olivier Messiaen
à l'auditorium de la batterie de
Guyancourt ce sera le vendredi 13
février à 20h30 le concert sera
accompagné de lecture par Catherine
Salvia sociétaire de la Comédie
Française tarif à partir de 9 euros en
voici un extrait
voilà et puis toujours en musique un
tout autre univers avec une artiste
ivinoise qui cherche du soutien pour
financer la sortie d'un album quatre
titres
son univers et celte et magique autour
de Merlin c'est le titre d'ailleurs de
sa première chanson Gwena est donc en
recherche d'un financement participatif
viennent plateforme bien connue pour
collecter 24200 euros je vous propose de
découvrir son Taser teaser pardon
dans sa tour des invisible attends que
sa belle délire
alors pourquoi Merlin parce que c'est un
univers qui me passionne depuis que je
suis toute petite et le jour où j'ai
enfin écrit cette chanson ça a été comme
une évidence donc nous avons réalisé le
clip et puis ensuite j'ai commencé à
écrire beaucoup d'autres chansons autour
de cette thématique
très rapidement l'envie est venue de
continuer cette aventure il existe donc
aujourd'hui un spectacle musical
entièrement écrit et qui a été proposé
une première fois sous forme de concert
de présentation
aujourd'hui pour continuer l'aventure
j'ai décidé de mettre en place un
financement participatif pour réaliser
et promouvoir dans un premier temps un
album quatre titres qui s'appelle RA
femme de Merlin derrière ce 4 titres il
y a toute une série de chansons qui
composeront un album qui s'intitulera la
nouvelle quête et pour ça j'ai besoin de
vous tous
et justement le financement participatif
de Gwenaëlle Roussel devait s'arrêter le
13 février l'auteur a décidé de le
plonger le quelques mois et nous en
parlerons à l'occasion de sa venue sur
le plateau de kiosque ce sera le 25
février
comme tous les mercredis vous en avez
l'habitude c'est l'acronique cinéphile
avec tout d'abord évidemment vos avis de
spectateurs
après il va pas dans le dans le trash
enfin d'après ce qu'on peut croire donc
je trouvais ça assez cool justement qui
s'écarte un petit peu justement des
détails du livre parce que ça permet de
voir un peu
quels sont justement ces 50 nuances de
folie sans forcément aller dans le trash
et puis c'est du tout public donc ça va
il est vraiment super bien enfin les
acteurs jouent très bien dedans mais
très déçu par la fin parce qu'on
s'attend à autre chose en fait c'est un
très bon film
faut aller le voir moi je le raconte pas
parce que faut le voir c'était pas mal
c'est un peu différent du livre il y a
quelques scènes un peu osées qui ont pas
été adapter mais sinon non c'était pas
mal passionnant de bout en bout un bon
film très bon film brillante ici je
salue
cette oeuvre qui est vraiment très très
bien interprétée excellent un très bon
Disney ils sont vraiment très efficaces
l'animation superbe
très belle histoire en plus
et maintenant on passe au coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du 7e art ce soir Luc
bocaux du ciné 7 délancourt
et deux coups de cœur si nécessaire de
cette semaine
ce très beau film Un qu'on a à la fiche
de plus très longtemps qui s'appelle
Timbuktu que dont vous avez dû entendre
parler ça se passe évidemment à
Tombouctou et ça raconte en fait la
façon c'est malheureusement d'actualité
dont les comment dirais-je les habitants
se retrouvent sous le joug des
islamistes qui leur donne tout un tas
d'obligations c'est très réaliste c'est
un film très triste c'est un très très
beau film avec de très belles images
notamment mais très bien joué aussi
et le deuxième c'est une promesse que
j'ai fait à échame Ayouche qu'on a reçu
qui est un réalisateur qu'on a reçu
mercredi dernier c'est son film fièvre
qui est un très beau film qui l'a pour
le coup se passe en banlieue et qui
raconte pardon la les relations
difficiles entre un fils qui n'a jamais
vécu avec son père et qui revient vivre
avec son père parce que sa mère est
emprisonnée son père vivant lui-même
avec ses propres parents
10 ans pour aimer
je vous en dis pas plus il y a une
séance ce samedi à 18h30 ça film qui est
sorti fin 2014 et qu'il faut absolument
voir fièvre du chamayouche au ciné 7 et
Timbuktu
en famille ce samedi à 10h30 à la
médiathèque des 7 mars des longs cours
c'est réservé un public dès l'âge de 3
ans vous découvrez l'univers de
l'artiste Alexandra fontaine qui a
exposé également à cette occasion et
pourra expliquer son travail l'entrée
est libre cette émission maintenant
terminée merci de l'avoir suivi
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine d'ici
là garder l'esprit ouvert et curieux à
très vite